(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Depois segue, na página 152, que essa tá
aqui, o juiz mandou um perito avaliar o
imóvel.
Então tá aqui o nome do perito, o
valor que o perito recebeu para avaliar aquele
imóvel, 3.500 reais, o prazo que o
perito tinha para avaliar aquele imóvel e tudo
mais.
O perito recebe essa determinação para avaliar, na
página 167 tem o laudo pericial, que é
esse que tá aqui.
Esse laudo pericial, ele tem 55 páginas, é
o mesmo laudo pericial que o próprio leiloeiro
já colocou aqui destacado.
Então você, como interessado, deveria analisar bem esse
laudo de avaliação e verificar se realmente você
consegue informações internas do condomínio e do apartamento
em si.
Voltando aqui para o processo, depois o condomínio,
ele pede, na página 226, o leilão do
imóvel.
Então tá aqui, considerando que aproxima-se a
etapa processal de alienação do bem por meio
de leilão judicial, o exequente, aí ele vem
indicar o leiloeiro que ele prefere que faça
o leilão.
Então ele indica, pede para o juiz que
realmente o juiz siga essa indicação dele.
Tem uma decisão do juiz, determinando o leilão,
e o juiz fala nomeia para a realização
da ação pública o gestor de sistema de
alienação judicial e coloca aqui o nome do
gestor e mais algumas regrinhas que o leiloeiro
deve observar.
Pagamento em 24 horas, que é a regra.
Atualização do valor pela tabela prática do Tribunal
de Justiça de São Paulo.
Os funcionários do leiloeiro ficam autorizados a providenciar
o cadastro de agendamento pela internet dos interessados
de vistoriar o bem empenhorado, cabendo a responsáveis
pela guarda, facultar o ingresso do interessado, designando
-se data para visita.
Essa visita aqui é muito difícil de ocorrer,
o próprio leiloeiro colocou lá que não era
possível, afinal de contas a executada está morando
dentro do imóvel, seria um fator de complicação
chegar lá um monte de interessado com a
pessoa que está perdendo o seu imóvel de
forma forçada.
Então realmente não foi possível a visita.
O processo continua e na folha 259 o
leiloeiro comunica as datas do leilão.
Começa a primeira praça primeiro de junho, duas
horas, encerra dia 4 de junho, segunda praça
começa dia 4 de junho, encerra dia 24,
o valor vai corresponder a 60% do
valor da avaliação, ou seja, 40% de
desconto e informa tudo mais.
Na folha 276 tem aqui a certidão de
publicação.
Repare, teve a decisão do juiz, ciente, aguarde
-se o leilão designado para o dia 1º
de junho e aí saiu essa decisão do
juiz no diário oficial.
A gente já sabe que quando tem advogado
constituído pelas partes, vale a intimação do advogado
no diário oficial.
Então saiu aqui certidão de publicação no diário
oficial, está aqui diário de Justiça Eletrônica, publicou
no dia 14 do 4, intimou os dois
advogados do condomínio, Marcia e Pérola, o advogado
da executada, que é o Ellison, intimou o
próprio leiloeiro.
Então está todo mundo sabendo que vai acontecer
aquele leilão, o advogado deve comunicar as partes,
tanto o advogado do condomínio, quanto o advogado
da executada, perfeitamente válido o requisito de intimação
sobre as datas do leilão, ok, tudo certo.
Esse leilão aqui então ainda estava todo correto
para você arrematar, você poderia arrematar sem erro,
o leilão aconteceu, teve arrematação e aí depois
eu vou mostrar só pra vocês como é
que funciona.
Na página 282 o leiloeiro informa que teve
arrematação.
O bem apenhorado nos autos foi arrematado em
segunda praça pelo valor de R$ 484
mil e aí ele pede para o juiz,
que é a vossa senência, anexar esses documentos
ao processo, autos de arrematação, comprovante de pagamento,
comprovante de pagamento da comissão do leiloeiro, comprovação
da publicação do edital e tudo mais.
E aí ele pede pra assinar e na
página 297 já seria o próprio arrematante, Bruno,
empresário na qualidade de arrematante do imóvel, ele
já vem pedir a carta de arrematação, deixa
eu descer aqui pra mostrar pra vocês, expedição
de mandados de missão na posse e a
carta de arrematação, acho que tá um pouco
mais aqui em cima, expedição de carta de
arrematação.
Então, só pra vocês saberem, logo depois que
o leiloeiro comunica ao juiz, o arrematante já
pode entrar no processo, então esse processo aqui
é tudo certo, seria isso aqui que você
teria que analisar no processo, essa verificação, apesar
de o processo ser grande aqui, 303 páginas,
ela é uma verificação muito tranquila, em algumas
horas você mata tudo e pode se sentir
perfeitamente seguro pra participar do leilão.
Bom, vamos aqui pra mais uma análise de
mais um imóvel que eu separei pra vocês.
Esse imóvel, ele foi anunciado pela ProAjud Leilões,
então tá aqui os dados, a primeira praça
aconteceu no dia 24 de março, fechou dia
27 de março, segunda praça começou dia 27
de março e fechou em dia 16 de
abril.
O valor da primeira praça R$ 265
.861,00, o valor da segunda praça R
$ 159.517,00.
Um apartamento na Penha, de dois dormitórios, terraço,
uma vaga, 50 metros quadrados.
Tem aqui as informações do processo, é também
uma dívida de condomínio contra o executado Paulo.
Vamos aqui abrir a matrícula.
E por que eu mostrei esse imóvel aqui
pra vocês?
Por que que eu separei eles?
Aqui a matrícula.
Primeira descrição do imóvel, proprietário, promorar e engenharia.
Registro número 1, o proprietário vendeu ao Paulo
e a Vanderlita, em 1990.
Registro número 2, o Paulo e a Vanderlita,
como novos proprietários, hipotecaram o imóvel em favor
do Banco Bradesco.
E aqui tem as condições de pagamento, o
valor da dívida, tá tudo certinho.
Registro, averbação número 3.
Por uma ordem do juiz da Sexta Vara
Cível da Capital, que era a Gabriela Fragoso,
a juíza, nos autos do processo, tem aqui
o número do processo, movido por Paulo e
Vanderlita, que são os proprietários do imóvel, contra
o Bradesco, a juíza determinou a essa serventia,
e essa serventia aqui que está falando é
o 12º Ofício de Registro de Imóveis, para
não efetuar nenhum registro nessa matrícula.
Ou seja, a juíza proibiu que ocorresse qualquer
registro nessa matrícula.
Continuando a matrícula, averbação 04.
Pela ordem do juiz da Sexta Vara Cível,
que nesse caso aqui já era o Alberto
Alonso, extraído nos autos do procedimento, tem aqui
o número do processo, tendo como requerente o
Paulo e outro, o outro provavelmente é a
mulher do Paulo, que é outra proprietária desse
imóvel, contra o Banco Bradesco, ficou cancelada a
averbação número 03.
Então não existe mais isso aqui, essa proibição
de registrar qualquer coisa nessa matrícula, não existe,
cancelada.
Averbação número 04, só para falar que foi
Averbação número 05.
Terceiro Ofício Cível do Foro Regional da Penha,
da capital de São Paulo, enviada pelo Tribunal
de Justiça de São Paulo, ocorreu a penhora
dos autos da execução civil, o número do
processo está aqui, valor da causa 37.915,
de um lado residencial Viladeixe, que é o
condomínio onde esse imóvel fica localizado, do outro
lado, Paulo e a Vanderlita.
Foi penhorado o imóvel, objeto dessa matrícula, sendo
nomeado depositário o Paulo Bonel dos Santos, que
é um dos proprietários.
Por que eu queria falar desse imóvel aqui
com vocês?
Porque tem uma hipoteca, repara, a hipoteca não
foi cancelada.
A hipoteca estava aqui no registro número 2,
teve a verbação número 3, a verbação número
4 cancelou a verbação 3, e a verbação
número 5 é a penhora da dívida de
condomínio, a hipoteca ainda está valendo, então tem
um credor hipotecário.
E para isso que eu separei esse imóvel,
para que vocês vejam como é que acontece
na prática a intimação do credor hipotecário, que
vai ser o requisito para que a hipoteca
seja cancelada.
Vamos só voltar aqui na página do leiloeiro.
O leiloeiro traz informações, tem aqui o número
do contribuinte, para que a gente usaria para
pesquisar no site da prefeitura de São Paulo
qual era o débito, isso aí você vai
replicar em qualquer leilão de seu interesse.
Ele apresenta aqui o valor da avaliação e
o débito de condomínio em aberto, era 120
mil até fevereiro de 2020.
Esse leilão aconteceu em março de 2020, então
esse débito já era um pouquinho maior, só
que ó, débito de 120 mil, valor da
arrematação 159.517, então o valor da arrematação
seria suficiente para quitar os débitos de condomínio.
Aqui também tem uma informação de que não
tem dívida de IPTU, certidão negativa, nada consta,
IPTU expedido em fevereiro de 2020.
E tem informação da hipoteca.
O que a gente precisa saber mesmo naquela
ordem de concurso de credores?
Que primeiro seria crédito alimentar, trabalhista e pensão
alimentícia.
Segundo, os débitos tributários.
Terceiro, os débitos com garantia real e depois
as outras penhoras.
Então, teoricamente, o credor hipotecário deveria receber antes
do condomínio, mas a gente estudou aquela exceção,
que é aquela súmula do STJ, que fala
que o condomínio recebe antes do credor hipotecário.
Então aqui nesse nosso caso, nem interessa se
o valor vai ser suficiente ou não para
pagar o crédito tributário, porque a primeira vai
receber o condomínio.
Se sobrar alguma coisa, recebe o credor hipotecário.
Se não sobrar também, o credor hipotecário, que
cobre de outra forma.
Afinal de contas, se ele for intimado da
existência da penhora na matrícula do imóvel que
tem hipoteca e depois sobre as datas do
leilão, tudo certo, aquela hipoteca vai morrer.
O juiz que determinou o leilão vai mandar
que o cartório cancele aquela hipoteca.
Eu abri aqui o processo, seria a mesma
forma como vocês receberiam quando um advogado enviasse
pra vocês.
Em primeiro lugar, a gente tem aquela petição
inicial, que é o condomínio de um lado
e a qualificação do condomínio, e do outro
lado o réu, os executados.
Então tá cobrando aqui a dívida, pediu o
bloqueio de valores da conta dos executados da
página 20 e o bloqueio também não deu
em nada.
Tinha no Banco Bradesco, zero reais, Santander, zero
reais, Caixa Econômica, tinha 35 reais, isso aqui
é insuficiente, nem bloqueia porque é irrisório.
Outro Banco Bradesco, também zero reais, Banco Santander,
zero reais, enfim, tentaram bloquear e não acharam
nada, só 35 reais pro valor da dívida
de 120 mil reais, 35 reais é zero,
o juiz nem bloqueia isso aí porque realmente
não adianta pra nada.
Na página 30, o condomínio, ele pediu a
penhora do imóvel.
Então vem aqui, a presença de vossa excelência,
falar que tinha um carro, mas que ele
não quer o carro porque não adianta, não
possui interesse na penhora do aludido bem, requerendo
a penhora do imóvel de onde se originam
as despesas condominais.
O juiz, então, na página 61, determina a
penhora do imóvel.
Nos termos do artigo 844 do Código de
Processo Civil, Lavra e Serventio, termo de penhora
referente ao imóvel indicado.
E aí na página 65, o juiz, ele
fala sobre a hipoteca.
Diante da certidão retromencionada, que foi uma certidão
do cartório falando que existia uma hipoteca, antes
de ser cumprida a ordem de folha 61,
que é a penhora do imóvel, esclareça ao
exeqüente se ainda há pendência acerca da hipoteca.
Então pediu para que o condomínio falasse se
a hipoteca ainda está valendo ou não.
E depois tem uma decisão que o condomínio
fala que realmente a hipoteca está valendo, o
juiz, ele manda cumprir a ordem de folha
61, que é penhorar aquele imóvel, mandou intimar
os executados por seu advogado acerca da conscrição
do bem, ou seja, os executados têm advogado
agindo em nome deles, basta que isso aqui
publique no diário oficial que os advogados vão
ter que repassar essa informação para o executado
e cumpre lá o requisito de intimação dos
executados.
E aí também pede para o exequente, que
é o condomínio, providenciar uma taxa para cientificar
o credor hipotecário.
Aqui na página 71, a gente tem certidão
de publicação de relação, foi publicado no Diário
de Justiça Eletrônico em agosto de 2017.
A penhora do imóvel, esse aqui de baixo,
Jorge Abraão, é o advogado dos executados, então
esse advogado dos executados deveriam repassar para eles
a informação de que o imóvel foi penhorado
para pagar a dívida e tudo certo, cumprir
o requisito de intimação da penhora.
Continua aqui, o juiz mandou, então, citar o
credor hipotecário, que nesse caso aqui é o
Bradesco.
Nas folhas 96, o Bradesco vem se manifestar.
Primeiro ele bota aqui a carta de intimação
que ele recebeu destinada ao Banco Bradesco.
Cidade ficou intimado de que efetivou uma penhora
sobre o imóvel que ele tem uma hipoteca.
E o Bradesco, ele continua aqui, vai ter
uma petição dele.
Essa advogada aqui do Bradesco, na verdade, o
que ela fez foi bem errado, acho que
ela não se atentou bem ao que ela
estava falando.
Ela tirou uma página aqui da consulta processual
desse processo, grifou as partes, que é de
um lado o condomínio, do outro lado Paula
e a Vanderlita, e falou que o Bradesco
não tinha nada a ver com aquele processo.
Na verdade, ela errou, porque a partir do
momento que tem uma hipoteca, o Bradesco deveria
se manifestar, pedir para que fossem reservados créditos
para pagar a hipoteca, enfim, tentar argumentar alguma
coisa.
E a advogada, ela veio aqui e falou,
ó, o Banco Bradesco foi intimado e por
sua advogada informa que recebeu a notificação eletrônica
dos autos e epigrafes.
Contudo, o Banco Bradesco não figura como parte
do processo.
Falou que o Bradesco não tem nada a
ver com aquilo ali.
E, vida que segue, e aí o juiz
mandou na página 101, deixa eu pular aqui,
o juiz determinou, ó, petição retro, o Banco
Bradesco fica através dessa decisão cientificada acerca da
penhora efetivada nas Folhas 80, onde o banco
é credor hipotecário.
Então, isso aqui é o requisito para que
a hipoteca seja cancelada.
Então, em primeiro lugar, vai ser pago aqui
o débito de condomínio, porque a gente já
estudou que existe aquela exceção do STJ, que
o débito de condomínio recebe antes do débito
da hipoteca.
Então, nem importaria saber quanto é que é
o valor dessa hipoteca aqui.
O Banco Bradesco foi notificado, tudo certinho, e
seria o requisito para cancelar.
E depois existe a decisão aqui, mandando o
imóvel a leilão, aqui com fundamento no artigo
882 do Código de Processo Civil.
Escolheu a gestora judicial pró-jú de leilões,
representada pelo leiloeiro Carlos Campanha, que é leiloeiro
oficial, inscrito na junta comercial 1053, e tudo
certo, colocou aqui as horas, ó.
Primeira praça, 24 de março de 2020, duas
horas, com término dia 27 de março, duas
horas, e depois a segunda praça, que iria
acontecer até dia 16 de abril, às duas
horas, com valor de desconto de 40%, afinal,
o lance mínimo seria aceito 60% da
valor da avaliação.
Então, é 40% de desconto que está
sendo oferecido em referência ao valor da avaliação.
Depois dessa decisão aqui, ela publica, ó, certidão
de publicação.
Publicou no Diário de Justiça Eletrônico, do dia
3 de 4.
Foram intimados advogado do condomínio, advogado do executado
e advogado do Bradesco.
Então, tudo certo, esse leilão poderia acontecer também
normalmente e a hipoteca seria cancelada.
O interessado nem mesmo precisaria se preocupar com
o valor do débito dessa hipoteca, afinal de
contas, só existem dois débitos na matrícula que
lhe movem, hipoteca e débito de condomínio.
A gente já estudou que o condomínio recebe
antes do criador hipotecário, então, se o valor
da arrematação fosse suficiente para quitar o valor
do condomínio, tudo certo, o condomínio recebe, a
prefeitura recebe.
Nesse caso aqui, especificamente, não existia débito de
IPTU, então a prefeitura também não tinha nada
a receber.
Seria pago o condomínio, se sobrasse algum valor
da arrematação, iria para o criador hipotecário.
A hipoteca seria cancelada, tudo certinho, afinal de
contas, o Bradesco, que era o criador hipotecário
nesse caso, foi notificado da penhora e depois
da data do leilão através de sua advogada
pelo Diário de Justiça Eletrônico.
Tudo certo, poderia participar.
É isso que você sempre deve ficar atento
nas análises dos seus editais.
Verifique realmente se foi certinho, leia o edital
com atenção, a matrícula com atenção, o processo
judicial que levou e move o leilão também
com atenção, só passe para o processo depois
de você analisar todos aqueles requisitos da matrícula,
do edital, o laudo de avaliação, que geralmente
os próprios leiloeiros já colocam ali destacado na
página do leilão.
Se não colocar, você vai conseguir encontrar dentro
do processo judicial.
Só passe para a análise do processo, realmente
se é a matrícula e o edital, você
verificar que está ok, que os débitos que
existem lá vão ser pagos com o valor
da arrematação, que tudo certo, que não existe
risco de sobrar para o arrematante.
Isso vai te dar muita segurança, entre sempre
em contato também anterior com o condomínio, tente
descobrir com porteiro, zelador, síndico, dados de quem
está ocupando aquele imóvel, se for numa casa
de rua, tente entrar em contato com algum
vizinho, peça informações, aí nesse caso como você
não vai ter nenhum dado do vizinho, compareça
pessoalmente, bata lá na porta, fale que você
é um interessado e veja o que você
consegue de informações, isso tudo vai ser muito
útil para te passar segurança.